berlin erster juni
2022 meine ganz persönliche zeitenwende
ich der leidenschaftliche autofahrer
kaufe mir zum ersten mal in meinem leben
ein bahnticket
ja
ich hab's ich hab das noch nötig
alter schwede der berliner
personennahverkehr wo steigt man jetzt
zuerst ein sind sie mal im berufsverkehr
in diversen sicherheit nicht zum 17 mal
drin gewesen ich ja nie so nah da kann
ja haben dittmar kennengelernt war
wirklich auf maske da ist alles so der
heute ja also ich hab ich hab soll ich
war ein tuareg der hat
volllederausstattung kost 105000 euro
aber da habe ich habe ich natürlich dab
radio höre ich manchmal höchst in
deutschland
habe ich habe ich schon mal gehört das
ja schlimm zugeht in der u-bahn wenn ich
eine u bahn steige was muss ich alles
dabei haben um taser ist klar
pfefferspray ist auch klar bodyguard ist
die frage kann der mit meinem neuen euro
ticket mitfahren oder musste extra
ziehen keine mitnahme allein die bvg hat
ja eine halbe millionen schon verkauft
das ist ein gehöriger anteil würde ich
500.000 zahlen der u bahn fahrer in
berlin das hat es noch nie gegeben hat
so vielleicht gar nicht gegeben hier
gibt es viele schwarzfahrer da stimmen
ja wie riecht so nacht nach pisse katze
ja und so war noch andere undefinierbare
gerüchte das ist die u8 die relation 8
wie riecht eine regionalbahn die richter
billigen bier würde ich sagen okay
irgendwelchen stingl fußballfans
das abenteuer beginnt
[Musik]
abstieg in den höllenschlund
das tor zu einer unbekannten welt
hallo ich bin der reifen ich bin
autofahrer das ist für mich das erste
mal
ist schon aufregend
gibt es von ihrer seite aus tipps was
ich zu beachten hätte
das ganze elend sich
[Musik]
ich habe so ein bisschen
so los geht's
das wird ja kräften riechen sie mal das
ist neu war die und
ja da würde ich sagen ist einfach mal zu
vergessen gibt es irgendwelche sachen
worauf ich achten müsste wenn ich jetzt
hier fahre mit der u-bahn ja diesen
genießt ja
geschlagene elf minuten in der u-bahn
bevor es lebensgefährlich wird breche
ich das experiment
[Musik]
es war anstrengend erstmal ein bisschen
entspannung auch nach sylt
[Musik]
oh gott der dreh für die nk